- [Instructor] In this
video we're going to talk
about one of the most important ideas
in mathematics and that's
whether order matters
when you multiply two numbers.
So for example, is three times four
the same thing as four times three?
Are these two things equal to each other?
And regardless of whether
these two are equal
to each other, is it always the case
that if I have some number times some
other number, if I swap
the order am I going
to get an equivalent number?
Well, pause this video and see
if you can work through that.
Try to think about that a little bit
before we think through it together.
Well, let's think through
this particular example.
And we're going to do so with
the help of some angry cats.
So we clearly see some angry cats here.
Meow.
Yes, they are angry.
We could view this as
three groups of four.
So this is one group right over here
of angry cats, four angry cats.
This is two groups of four angry cats.
And this is three groups
of four angry cats
if we view the first number here as groups
of the second number.
But we could also view it
as four groups of three.
How would we do that?
Well, we could have one
group of three angry cats.
We can have two groups
of three angry cats.
We can have three groups
And we could of course have
four groups of three angry cats.
So based on that, if you think of it,
the first number as groups
of the second number,
well, it seems like the
order doesn't matter.
Another way you could think about it
is here you have four
rows of three angry cats.
You have one, two, three, four rows
of one, two, three angry cats.
And so to figure out how many total cats
you have, you multiply four times three.
But you could view this
same group of angry cats
but just view it with a
slightly different perspective.
So here we have our angry cats.
And then let me rotate our angry cats,
probably risking making
them a little bit angrier.
Let me move them back in.
And now, we could view this as three rows,
one, two, three, of four cats in each row.
So let me put all of these upright.
So we have one, two,
three rows of one, two,
three, four cats.
Don't wanna look at those 'cause it might
make us a little bit confused.
And we're dealing with the
exact same number of cats.
And so I'm only dealing
with three and four here
but what you will see
is order doesn't matter
when you are multiplying two numbers.
And we could also see
that on a number line.
And we could do that
with multiple examples.
I'll keep a couple of angry cats here
looking at us just to keep us in check.
If we wanna think about three times four
we could view it as four threes.
So three, six, nine, 12.
Or we could view it as three fours.
Four, eight, and 12.
And I focused a lot on three and four
but we could do it with any two numbers
that we're trying to multiply together.
So let's say we wanted to do that with,
I don't know, let's see
whether six times four,
whether it's the same
thing as four times six.
Well, you could view it as six fours.
Four, eight, 12, 16, 20, and then 24.
Or you could view it as four sixes.
One six, 12, 18, and 24.
So big takeaway, order doesn't matter
when you are multiplying
numbers like this.
And this is sometimes referred
to as the commutative property.
It's a fancy word but
it's really just saying
that whether you're doing six times four
or four times six the commutative property
of multiplication says,
"Hey, those two things
"are going to be equivalent."
Meow.
Yes, they are angry for being rotated.